hey time for another movie retrospective
I know it's like not the right time of
year to be doing this movie but any time
of the year is the right time well we
just did Creepshow horror movies and
halloween we did like creep show too and
this movie kind of spiritually is very
much on the same line as creep show yeah
you know I liked it yeah this is also an
anthology film it's not as old as some
of the other ones we do this is actually
from 2007 yeah
trick-or-treat yeah it's worthy of creep
show though I agree
yeah it's worthy of that and the same
director that did Krampus yeah and he's
also gonna do the new Godzilla was it uh
Godzilla king and the king of the king
of the monster which is just coming out
there she's coming out so would you
actually I'd even know that when I plan
to do this so I was like oh we're going
to see cats rocking in the monsters this
week so that worked out so this is
actually kind of relevant to today yeah
and he said that there may be a sequel
to this if king of the monsters does
real well yes well I mean after when he
said after like all the Godzilla stuff
was was over and like he wanted to do a
sequel of this just because I mean the
sad thing about this movie um you know
there's been a lot of good horror movies
you know I I think that we're kind of in
something of a Golden Age of horror
movies at the moment like even for the
past 10 20 years even but the sad thing
about this one is that it came out it
was made in 2007 it kind of made the
rounds of like horror festivals and
stuff audiences loved it um it won all
kinds of awards and [ __ ] like that but
for some reason I think it was Warner
Brothers that owned the rights and they
did not think that it merited a
theatrical release crazy it never got a
widespread theatrical release that's the
actual release no it do not and then
just and then like 2 years later like in
2009 they put it out on DVD
those dudes don't know what they're
talking about right now they're dissing
on [ __ ] bright burn and bright burn
was awesome I really liked yeah they're
some of the critics are talking about
how bad bright burn was man bright beer
was awesome is like there's no soy in
that I really liked all the gore in it
yeah but the thing so what happened with
trick-or-treat was that it was so
successful on video like it got really
good
mouths and it eventually got this huge
huge huge cult following and now he'll
it's like it's so well-known that even
like Universal Studios and [ __ ] like
that they even have at Halloween Horror
Nights they do a trick-or-treat themed
house with little Sam the little you
know the little pumpkin headed guy with
the burlap sack on his head what's his
name
Sam Sam that's a good that's an
interesting aspect of this movie now you
know Christmas has Santa yeah you know I
mean and you know you got the Easter
Bunny but there isn't anything for
Halloween yeah so what what does movie
tries to do that tries to establish a
regular character to symbolize her to
personalize Halloween and it says little
like a little child with a pumpkin head
it's for its it's weird yeah he's like a
little demon he's like supernatural um
and he he has like a gross like scary
face but he usually goes around with
this little like round burlap sack on
his head with a little face and he's
like super super cute little orange
footie pajamas little jack-o'-lantern
lollipop and a little candy bag and yes
so Michael Dougherty the guy that wrote
and directed this movie he said exactly
that he's like you know all these
holidays had all these like you know
iconic figures to go with them but for
some reason Halloween didn't have one so
he wanted to kind of establish that
character yeah to me he's got kind of
like a skull like head it looks like
cross doing like a skull and a pumpkin
yeah that's what that's exactly what he
looks like and he is essentially alien
yeah his face looks a little bit like
what a bag comes off yeah yeah
but I think essentially what he is is
he's kind of like the Halloween enforcer
yeah like if he thinks you're not doing
it right or you're not enjoying
Halloween enough or respecting Halloween
traditions then he will [ __ ] you up yeah
yeah but that is one thing in the
halloween quality-control age that's
exactly now the thing that I love about
this movie and that a lot of people love
about this movie this is kind of like
the quintessential Halloween movie I
mean yes there's John Carpenter's
Halloween but some people have pointed
out yes that's a horror movie yes
set on Halloween but it didn't have to
be set on Halloween in fact it wasn't
even originally set on Halloween I don't
think because originally the idea was it
was called the babysitter murders so
they the producer later said of March
sitter on holidays there's like pumpkins
and [ __ ] but it's not it doesn't have to
be Halloween but trick-or-treat the
whole you know the whole fiber of its
being is all about Halloween and it's
all about old-school Halloween it all
takes place on one Halloween night in
this like Midwestern town I think it's
called Warren Valley I think is in Ohio
and it's just like four or five like
interconnected stories in this
neighborhood and all of them have to do
with Halloween traditions yeah and it
kind of had a bunch of animated
sequences in it to make a comic book
movie to kind of kind of like Creepshow
mostly just the beginning just like the
beginning the beginning credits look
very much like Creepshow and like I said
I think this has a slightly different
vibe than Creepshow but I think this is
just as good a horror anthology it's
good it I like the tone I did see it's a
good combination of fun and colorful but
then kind of gory yeah there's a good
comment and kind of sick and it's kind
of funny like it has like a lot of black
humor and it just kind of like creeped
sure did yeah a lot of kids get killed
in this yeah it's a little more hardcore
than Creepshow I would think I kinda I
mean yeah so maybe it's just cuz it's
more modern yeah maybe that's what it is
you know but it I think it I think it's
a worthy addition to those kind of
movies I mean you know it stands on its
own
you know stands it stands right
alongside him yeah and like I said a lot
of people have said this is like the
perfect Halloween movie it's like the
whole the whole tone of it the whole
look of it it's just it's very orange
it's like there's jack-o'-lanterns
everywhere it's like super cool and you
know coming from somebody like me who's
like I love Halloween and I've always
loved Halloween this is like really the
movie you put on at the party and you
know and the cool thing about it is it's
an anthology so you don't really have to
like you know pay too much attention you
that right although I have to say what I
like it when I'm drunk
well yeah well one of the things I like
about it is that it does have practical
effects and they're very good practical
effect yeah there it made it had some CG
but I didn't really detect it was there
CG in it I don't really remember any CG
ate it I don't remember seeing any
either if there was it was very minor
and it was noticeable and good because
if you can't notice the CJ then well
yeah that's the whole point of see I was
interpreting it as kind of an homage to
to Creepshow yeah you know I mean and
and it was you know and I thought it had
be even better practical effects of
course you know because it's more modern
but yeah the way it was shot you know
just good looking movie real good it
wasn't like I said you know even though
you know if you didn't know like the
kind of convoluted trail that it took
like to get to you know to get to our
release you would think wow this looks
really good for a direct-to-dvd movie
but that's because it wasn't supposed to
be a direct-to-dvd movie was supposed to
be you know I had no say in the theaters
I had no I never did this this was you
know a good movie it should have played
in theaters well yeah and I and I think
that that was something that a lot of
people once a lot of people saw it and
like I said it got like a huge cult
following and it got like you know
hugely famous later on and I think a lot
of people were like that's just like I
think I was looking at one of those
horror sites Bloody Disgusting or
something like that so that's like
criminal that it never got yeah they're
like it's so good and I've never got
released remember the horror movie that
we saw that was taking place in the
[ __ ] amusement park what was that
called do you mean Hellfest hellfish
exam the theater yeah yeah better in
hell fast this is a hell yeah I would
say better than what's the one the the
room the one about riddle rooms what's
it called
more they're trying to scape an escape
room better an escape room yeah even
though I like scape room this is better
like I said this is better than most and
it's definitely in the top five corner
anthologies ever I think yeah yeah
definitely and what one thing that it
did and I've only seen a couple of other
anthologies that did this it's not like
Creepshow where it's like one story
after another it's actually four or five
stories happening concurrently or you
know on the same night and yeah their
inner woven so it'll kind of cut back
and forth between them and like
sometimes it'll go back in time to like
show you what happened from like the
other person's perspective like so all
of the stories are kind of related but
you know but it's just it's four or five
separate stories and one thing I noticed
that what I've actually watched it twice
for this review and you pick up new
things like every time you see it
because all of the stories it's just
really clever the way they kind of like
fit them all together and you don't have
to notice it you can just like enjoy the
stories the way they are but I like it
more when you like pay attention and you
see like all these little details then
it's like oh that relates back to the
show and that's what that guy was doing
and that's this person like walking by
and all this other kind of stuff so I
think that's really cool the way they
integrated it like one thing that I
didn't catch the first time around and
you know just like most other things
this is gonna have spoilers so you know
if you don't want spoilers then turn it
off right now okay yeah okay but one
thing I didn't realize the first time
around was that in the story within a
story where the one girl was telling the
legend about all the mentally challenged
kids on the bus and then the bus driver
was got paid by their parents to like
drive them off a cliff like into a
quarry or whatever that bus driver in
the past was mr. Krieg the crabby
Halloween hating old guy that lived next
door to the principal that was also a
serial killer yeah he ended up paying
for that [ __ ] though he did yeah well I
have to say and I'm not I don't even
know if I could pick like my favorite
story in this because they're all so
interrelated I mean I think the
principal serial killer is probably my
favorite just because I love that actor
and he was just like so [ __ ] good in
it and he's like you know he's like
murdering little kids and getting his
little kid to help out and [ __ ] like
that but the the one where they had you
know the kids and the bus and then there
are these four kind of kind of [ __ ]
kids kind of
kids and they have this idea that
they're gonna go and get all these
jack-o'-lanterns and take them as like
an offering quote-unquote to the kids
that died at the bottom of the quarry
and they end up going to the house of
this girl that they call Rhonda the
[ __ ]
this is like and it's so funny because
there's they go oh is that Rhonda the
retards house she's not a [ __ ] she's
an idiot savant
yes she's spirited and I said this
little girl it's like she's so she has
portable which she gets forty bajillion
like jack-o'-lanterns in her yard and it
looks super super cool and she's carved
all of them she made her costume it's
like a really good witch costume and
she's all kind of like nerdy and awkward
and I'm like oh I love and the the cool
thing about it too is that I mean the
bullies are kind of like nice to her
because they want the pumpkins and I
think that their plan was they were
gonna scare the [ __ ] out of her so
they're acting like they're nice to her
and the one guy is like kind of flirting
whether suppo did you make all these and
they're so pretty and blah blah blah and
so they take her to this quarry and then
they basically dress up like zombies and
make it seem like you know the kids
killed them and they were gonna come
back and get her and she freaked the
[ __ ] out as you would and then they're
like no no we're just joking except then
the mentally challenged kids from the
bus they really do come back as zombies
and then they're gonna kill the bully
kids and the little girl gets in the
elevator to go to the back of the quarry
she's like see yeah I'm like that's what
you get for being mean to that little
girl
yeah thank you movie though I liked it
yeah um also like I said my favorite my
favorite part is the the principal guy
because he's like okay so he's out and
then this little fat kid who you know is
an [ __ ] because he's going around
like knocking off knock it everybody's
pumpkins off the fence and breaking up
and [ __ ] like that so he goes up and the
principal has a little pumpkin on there
it's like oh we're out just take one
piece of candy and you know the fat kids
not gonna do that he like digs his hand
in there and he's like digging them all
out and then the principal comes back
and he's all like he's like what are you
doing
he's like sits down next to him and then
it turns out that he has poisoned all
the candy yeah and the fat kid starts
barfing and it's it's I think it's
cyanide because there's like a bunch of
bottles yeah the kid throws up and it
goes on for a long time I don't stand by
me they're all bark finger yeah they try
they try to design the scene to make you
on a dry heave yeah yeah because he's
throwing up all chocolates and yeah it
looks like he's barfing up diarrhea
except it's not lumpy which that's
probably good because otherwise I
wouldn't be able to watch but then the
funny thing she was the principal he's
like burying these kids in his backyard
and he has a little a little son - and
the little son is like Daddy you need to
come and help me like Carvin jack a man
above died and you you are led to
believe that the principal is gonna end
up killing his own kid but in a twist
what he ends up doing is he cut off that
fat kid's head yeah and he's helping the
little kid like carve a jack-o-lantern
face
so he's like raising the next generation
of serial killers which I thought was
nice so like I said you thought that was
nice well no it's like because one you
don't feel it's unexpected you think
he's gonna kill the yeah turns eyestrain
the kid yeah he's trained as a kid to be
yeah he's like well I'm not gonna be
around forever to see real kill and
poison kids on ya Halloween and stuff
like that so I need to like pass the
torch along but yeah so you cuz you
don't see that a lot in movies this this
movie reminds me a lot actually of
Halloween 3 season of the witch it has
kind of like a similar favorite movie
yeah it's very Halloween infused and
it's also fun but kids don't get spared
like a lot of kids get killed in this
movie okay and I like that I mean I
don't like kids getting killed obviously
but you know a lot of movies don't
really have the balls to do that yeah
well this director you know you
obviously knew all these old cool movies
we grew up with so he's just gonna yeah
do a lot pay a lot of homage to the
classics you know
oh yeah and at the time you know
Halloween fans were furious at Halloween
3 I never saw one and 2
the first Halloween movie I saw was
Halloween 3 ah yeah
so you didn't I [ __ ] love gin yeah I
[ __ ] live to this day I love that
movie
and if you show me Halloween 1 and 2 I'm
just I think it's kind of boring to me
I'd you know I liked Halloween 3 well
like I said I feel like trick-or-treat
and Halloween 3 season of the witch or
like a good double feature yeah like for
your Halloween party
yeah because they're both they're both
weird they're both super into the ha and
they're into like the old traditions of
the holiday Halloween 3 season of the
witch thought I'd have to kind of give
it the nod because it is weirder it is I
know it's not as technically good as
trick-or-treat yeah it retreats a pretty
movie you know it is a beautiful
beautiful look coming three in its day
was let's say it was a workman like move
yeah there was good this is getting away
with what they could get away with you
know for all for cheap yeah and it has
some [ __ ] bad-ass scenes if you had
kids heads exploded into snakes and
brooches awesome you know awesome stuff
magic it's great you know
yeah just good movies but like I said I
like there there's no soundtrack there's
not a really lot of movies that delve
this deeply into like Halloween
traditions and you know Halloween 3 is
one of them and trick-or-treat is
definitely one of them too
even though it's even though like I said
it goes into like the old history and
you know traditions and stuff but it
also kind of invent some new ones like
at the very beginning this couple is
coming back from a Halloween party and
obviously they didn't have a good time
because they're fighting and stuff and
the wife is just stick in the mud who
doesn't like Halloween and she's
basically telling the husband it's like
you have to get all this [ __ ] out
because he is decorated like alcohol I
count of them all over the [ __ ] yard
in two and it looks rad and then she's
all like no you have to take this down
like tonight like even though it's still
Halloween just like my mom's coming
tomorrow and she's gonna flip out when
she sees all this blah blah blah and
she's just being an [ __ ] and then she
does something very and Sam is watching
her behind you know we don't know that
until later
Pumpkinhead Halloween boy this yeah so
he's watching to make sure cuz he's
probably like hazed
but he doesn't like Halloween ever yeah
I'm gonna have to do this now shake
right this guy and she blows out the
jack-o'-lantern which that's like a new
rule I guess so because I never heard
you don't blow out the jack-o'-lantern
before oh we know suck a big-ass
lollipop about this wide in your mouth
face up and cut her all up because
because all of the you know arms Alexa
there's right out in front along yeah it
was it was pretty cool that was that I
said that was like the opening scene of
the film yeah it was Sam like taking
revenge for her blowing out the
Jacqueline and also just kind of being a
douche about Halloween in general and
want to take all the décolleté I'm
talking about is this movie makes you
want to see it again
I don't we saw it twice yeah yeah we
watched it well cuz here's what happened
and you're making me want to see
Halloween 3 yeah well we have both of
these movies cuz what did it happen a
make me want to see dead buried yeah
remember that one yeah yeah of course I
remember another one I guess because I
remember watching dead and buried and
Halloween 3 around the same era yeah on
you know HBO cinemax in a creepy old
[ __ ] movies man yeah yeah weird even
though that's not a Halloween movie is
so manga zombie movie but yeah remember
it's all from you know growing up you
know growing up with that weird [ __ ]
this movie there may be trick-or-treat
it's like every time I see it it makes
me want to have a big giant Halloween
party yeah I just play it on all this I
hope they do us a sequel to this I hope
they do too like I said Michael
Dougherty wanted to do and they're
certainly like enough crit enough
critical interns I mean this has like
almost universal needs to have a
theatrical release yeah it really does
I'm it just makes me sad that that ever
happened it's like so many shitty movies
get theatrical releases and this one
never did and this one is just like such
a good movie and it's just like I said
it's just that old school like Halloween
feel like when you were a kid and like
there's all this Jacqueline's it's all
dark and everybody else in the letter to
MC to do a theatrical re-release they're
re-releasing certain things release in
all movies they should do that they
actually what they should do is that
maybe like a weekend around Halloween
they should have this they should have
Halloween 3 season the wish they could
do like a marathon
right
marathon that would be totally rad and
then they could have like a [ __ ]
costume party and all that kind of [ __ ]
but yeah I really really would like to
do that I also want to UM say that
Oh Anna Paquin is in this from True
Blood she plays like a character that's
uh it's her and all her friends you
think that they're gonna get murdered
because they're just like all these
[ __ ] princesses and stuff although she
just dresses up like Red Riding Hood but
you know the whole beginning of the film
they're just like let's put on these
slick [ __ ] princesses - their titties
hanging out every and they look hot yeah
hot chicks maybe every flavor - but like
you think so they're going around like
picking up random dudes like to go to a
party with them and stuff like that and
then you think that one of them gets
like attacked by what seems to be a
vampire but then it turns out that
they're really werewolves and they're
like kind of picking all these guys up
so they could eat them later but yeah
there's just so much about this movie
it's they don't make a lot of horror
movies like this anymore like I said
last [ __ ] it's just it has a classic
feel to it it's super fun it's super
gory but just like a really good 80s
horror movie on steroids with like state
of the art practical effects for 2007
yeah it was like I edit and they looked
I could tell you he looked at Creepshow
anyone I want mine to be like davon even
tighter and I kind of did that same
thing yeah cuz it's very similar to
creep shell like I said even though the
stories aren't one one one after the
other they're all inner well you did
their own innovation but yeah innovated
on it cuz it he didn't want to do a
direct ripoff yeah he's just like it was
just a no Maj to that yeah it was
definitely the the opening credits were
an eyewash to that now I should say too
that if what ended up happening was that
I had actually not seen this movie at
the time we were at AMC Theaters the
other day like we do every week and then
we had like all this time in between the
movies so we went over to the food court
like cuz there's a mall right across the
parking lot and we went over there to
get something to eat and then we still
had like 45 minutes or an hour for the
movie started yeah so we went into I
think it was FYE
yeah and they had a [ __ ] ton
used dvds and storage in the front and
so I like went through they were like 3
bucks 5 bucks [ __ ] like that so I
started looking through their
trick-or-treat was in there and I was
like woo boo oh I'm having that the ring
was in there so we're gonna do a reveal
that last house on the left was in there
so so I ended up picking up a bunch of
movies that were gonna be reviewing and
trick-or-treaters
obviously yeah and the blu-ray of this
looks really good you not put it on you
know on aren't new no it's a DVD I do it
I meant I meant was is that the the DVD
looks really good yeah it looks like a
blu-ray quality yeah that's the quality
oh that's what I wanted to say I was
pretty impressed with the way it looked
it does that looks really nice yeah like
if you were to get a blu-ray edition it
probably wouldn't look much better yeah
might be worth it I think it was shot on
in this format it probably is best seen
in that format yeah if a blu-ray release
came out we just have a bunch of extras
yeah which some people might want that
they're probably one with a bunch of
extras that's what I'm yeah I'm
wondering about that because I think I
mean I'm not sure when the blu-ray came
out so I'm sure this is out on blu-ray
at this point but see the DVD that I
have the only extra that it has is a
little short animated film that Michael
Dougherty made in 1996 I believe where
he introduced the Sam character he looks
a little bit different and like I said
it's like a cartoon it's only about five
minutes long of him just kind of going
around with his little treat bag and
like holding it up and letting you know
who's just like cracked me up how he was
like going out like candy yeah and then
you know and and there was like a little
twist at the end
so that's on there and I think that
there's like a what do you call it when
he's on there like talking about it
Oh commentary the commentary just for
the short I think that that's all that's
on the DVD so if you well if you really
loved this movie and you don't have it I
would probably recommend getting the
blu-ray if there's extra [ __ ] on it
because the DVD only has that one thing
yeah um it doesn't have a trailer no I
don't even think it has commentary in
the movie it only has commentary yeah
but from what I saw if you want to save
a few bucks and you came across like a
cheap DVD copy yeah this I got it looks
good
yeah it looks
it looks good it looks it looks as good
as a blue right to me I thought it did
too and you know like I said it's just
such a nice looking movie it's just very
it looks very crisp and it looks like
fall colors are right
yeah orange and brown it's like really
really nice but yeah so like I said you
can't go wrong with [ __ ]
trick-or-treat man I don't I don't know
a single person that does yeah it does
not like this the first time I thought
you know I hadn't heard of it before I
just thought it was maybe some kind of
low-budget knockoff type movie I'd never
didn't know anything about it yeah I was
like blown away it's like yes good man
really good yeah see I had been hearing
a lot about it because like I said
periodically I go through lists um
you know best horror movies of the 2000s
best horror movies of the 2010s just to
make sure that I'm like keeping up with
[ __ ] because I don't want to be like
only old movies I want to like see new
ones cuz there's a lot of really good
and it's hard to believe it's 2007 it
did that movie didn't look that old it
really didn't age well I mean it looks
like something maybe came out two or
three years ago
yeah you can't really it's not that I'm
thinking about it other than maybe like
the cell phones but there's not there
wasn't a lot of cell phone [ __ ] in the
movie so it's like it didn't really
stand out to me it's like oh look at
that old cell phone yeah no age well I
don't even I don't even remember seeing
I didn't really remember the years of
the cars the cars oh yeah straight me is
looking at old just you know yeah it
didn't even occur to me that that's like
how long ago it was [ __ ] that was 12
years ago now yeah but yeah it totally
doesn't look it doesn't look that old
yeah so [ __ ] man sings about four years
old maybe well you know if you haven't
seen this movie like I said you got to
see this movie it's really really good
doesn't have to be Halloween although
you know it helps if it's Halloween and
it's it's like the perfect movie to put
on at your Halloween party I watch that
[ __ ] anytime yeah well you re watching
for Halloween every day is Halloween
that's right you know how that goes all
right so let's wrap up our retrospective
of the 2007 movie trick-or-treat go
check it out also if you would like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to have a one time donation it'd be
much appreciated
our movie retrospectives just like this
one right here come out every Friday and
also our 13 o'clock matinee which is
three new movies in the theater that
comes out every Sunday and our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday if you
are a patriotic on on our patreon page
blah then you will get access to all the
shows a day early so that's kind of neat
if you want to do that so that'll do it
for this installment we will see you
next time bye